ich bin ganz besonders stolz und happy
dass sie zu klicks und kommt nora
tschirner eine der meistgebuchten
schauspielerin zur zeit in deutschland
und im moment ist sie im kino nicht zu
sehen aber zuhören beim neuen disney
pixar film merida worum es da geht und
vor allem was sie zu euren fragen sagt
das werdet er die tage hier auf dich zum
erfahren und wenn ihr fragen stellt dann
am besten in den kommentaren oder noch
besser als video upload einfach in die
kommentare box klicken rechts daneben
dann der button zum hochladen seit
einfallsreich lest den info texte und
dann stehen die chancen eigentlich
ziemlich gut dass ihr dran kommt ich
drücke die daumen und nora tschirner
freut sich schon und bevor ich es
vergesse den trailer zum film gibt's im
video hier unten verlinkt schnell ganz
spezielle aktion mit meiner kollegin
janet johnson viel spaß dabei